-I don't know when
we're gonna have
award shows again,
and so I'm particularly happ
that we got to see you hos
the Globes last year.
I am always delighted.
Now, did you enjoy going bac
and hosting the Globes again
-I did.
It just -- It seems like
a bygone era, all the things
you worry about, you know?
When the -- I -- You know,
the last couple of times
I've done it, they offered m
to, and I said no at first
and they persuaded me,
and this was no different.
I said no, then they persuaded
me through flattery and cash
And the first thing I thought,
"Christmas is ruined,"
so I wrote jokes.
But, yeah, I had a blast.
And, um, it was so funny,
because I think
you hosted the Emmys,
didn't you?
You were --
-Yeah.
-You were brilliant.
I thought it was --
I thought you were
absolutely brilliant.
But you probably
put a lot of work in.
And I heard that
most presenters, like,
they really work hard for weeks.
They have a team of writers,
and they go in,
you know, a few weeks before
now and again.
I can't do that
'cause I live in London.
So, I turn up the day before
with, like, a piece of paper
and I've got about 20 jokes,
right?
And all you have to do --
I don't show it to anyone,
I don't have to, I don't
rehearse or anything like that
But I do have to show it
to a lawyer
just to make sure I don't brea
the law and libel anyone
or, you know,
break taste and decency.
And I never have.
I've always read it to a lawyer,
you know, an hour before
and they've gone,
"Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine."
This time, I went to a room,
and there was about 15.
Now, I don't know if that wa
they're getting more nervous
about me
or the times have changed,
you know?
-Sure.
-But, obviously,
networks are very nervous.
And this is, like,
prime time, you know?
It goes out 5:00 p.m. in L.A
So, anyway --
So, I do the monologue.
It's a tough crowd,
15 executives and some lawyers
Right?
But I do it, and it's fine
You know,
they say that there was --
you know, there was an ISIS joke
about they'd sign up
to a streaming service.
They'd do anything,
these actors.
There was a thing about
sweat shops, and they went
"Yes, that's fine.
Fair satire."
There was a joke about
"The Two Popes" film
being a pedophile movie.
They went, "Fine."
The big discussion was the rif
on the movie "Cats."
-Sure.
-So, Dame Judi Dench said it was
the role she was born to pla
'cause she likes nothing mor
than plumping herself down
on the carpet,
lifting her leg,
and licking her own minge.
Now, they worried about
"minge," right?
I said, "It's a British term
It's a cute term.
It's not offensive at all.
It's not a swear word."
They went, "Oh, okay."
And then, one of them
looked it up and said,
"It says
vulgar term for vagina."
And I went,
"Well, all slang is gonna be -
is a vulgar term, isn't it?"
I said, "what can I do?"
And the lawyer went,
"You can say vagina."
I went,
"I'm not gonna say vagina.
That's worse!
That's so clinical,
about Dame Judi Dench."
And he went, "I take it back."
Right?
So, we went through words
that I might be --
All I'm trying to do
is them not bleep it,
'cause it sort of ruins it
So, I persuaded them
that "minge" was fine, okay?
Such a weird -- We went through,
I said, "What about flange?"
And they went,
"Oh, that's a part of a sink
That'll confuse people."
So, I'm desperate.
So, we settle on minge.
Right?
And they said
they wouldn't bleep it.
And they still did.
But I knew they would,
so I pointed.
So...
-A workaround.
You found a workaround.
[ Both laugh ]
So, you know,
when I host award shows,
you know, there's so much
discussion about what's too far,
what's not too far.
I assume that you, even if
you're working by yourself
you have to know
that people expect you
to have at least two or thre
two-part jokes.
Are those fun to look for?
-Yeah. I mean,
I think you can do it --
I think you can do it,
in general.
You can go to
the elephant in the room
if something really
awful has happened, and it's -
And I'm gonna
go after their behavior,
like, I did the joke about
Felicity Huffman,
you know,
making the number plates.
Again, it's those things that,
you know, are in the room,
and they're fine.
I try and go for their, as I
say, their behavior, in general.
And I go after Hollywood
pretension, you know?
And this year, I thought, I went
after the fact that a hypocrisy,
I guess, that people were tire
of being lectured by --
Know what I mean?
People are tired of being told
to recycle by someone
who came to that gig in a limo
and got a private jet
to the limo.
So, I sort of did that angle
But I've got
nothing against anyone there
And you -- you sort of build
You sort of build to it.
And I think if you're goin
after the people in the room
in front of them,
I think that's enough.
I think that's
exciting enough for people
You don't have to go crazy
and really undermine
the moral fabric of America.
You're teasing rich people who
are winning awards, you know
It's not a room
full of wounded soldiers.
These are -- They're fine.
They're fine.
[ Laughs ]
-Well, it's always fun
watching you do it.
And we will be right back
with more Ricky Gervais.